Esta es la pregunta del millón de dólares: ¿Por
qué Putin quiere una guerra abierta en Ucrania? O,
al menos ¿Por qué Putin quiere que la OTAN
piense que quiere una guerra en Ucrania?
Puede parecer una obviedad pero seguro que pocos
sabríais darme una respuesta. Pensadlo así,
Rusia está en un momento realmente malo. Las
cosas como son. Podemos decir que llevan en una
crisis económica desde la invasión de Crimea...
¡Y eso ocurrió en 2014! Cuando hablamos de crisis
económica, tenemos que pensar en una auténtica
debacle con episodios cercanos a la hiperinflación
A todo esto hay que sumarle las sanciones
económicas, que todavía siguen presentes. Y el
hecho de que entrar en guerra abierta con Ucrania
supondría perder a casi todos los clientes de gas.
En VisualPolitik hemos hablado mil veces
de la dependencia que tiene Europa del
gas ruso. Pero esa dependencia tiene otra
cara: Europa también es el mejor cliente
de Rusia. De poco sirve tener enormes
reservas de gas si no lo puedes vender.
Y, finalmente, la guinda del pastel: el
coronavirus. Por mucho que Rusia sacara
la vacuna Sputnik V, su economía
también ha sufrido la pandemia.
Dicho de otra forma: la economía rusa no está
para muchos riesgos. Pero además... ¿Por qué
Ucrania? ¿Qué puede ganar Putin controlando
Ucrania? ¿Recursos naturales? Meeeh... poca
cosa hay en este país ¿Riqueza? ¿Empresas? ¡Para
nada! Ucrania es el país más pobre de Europa.
Dicho de otra forma ¿No haría mejor
Putin en centrarse en su propio país?
Durante estos días, seguro que habréis
oído toda clase de explicaciones de lo
más rocambolescas. Algunos llegan a comparar a
Putin con el protagonista de alguna telenovela
venezolana. Uno de esos hombres celosos que le
dice a su exmujer “¡Si no eres mía, no serás
de nadie!”. Pero, seamos claros: la política
internacional es más compleja que todo esto.
No os vamos a engañar, aquí, en VisualPolitik
no somos precísamente fans de Putin. Sí, es
cierto que en algún momento le hemos tenido como
mascota del canal o incluso hemos hecho chistes
sobre él. Pero cualquiera que nos conozca sabe
que somos bastante anti Putin. Ahora bien, eso no
significa que nos sirva un argumento de hombre de
paja. Así que en este vídeo vamos a explicar cual
es la narrativa y las razones reales de Rusia
para justificar una posible guerra. Y lo vamos
a hacer porque, línea editorial aparte, somos
independientes. Este canal no está financiado
por nadie más que nuestros patreons y nuestros
anunciantes. No todos pueden decir lo mismo.
Por cierto, que si queréis formar parte activa de
la comunidad VisualPolitik y queréis apoyar este
proyecto, os recuerdo que tenemos nuestro Patreon.
No sólo podéis colaborar con este proyecto para
que siga siendo independiente sino que además
recibiréis regalos exclusivos como merchandising
o nuestra newsletter de análisis político. SI os
interesa, tenéis los enlaces en la descripción.
Pero sigamos con nuestra historia. Porque la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos es ¿Qué interés
tiene Rusia en Ucrania? ¿De verdad son legítimas
sus razones para arriesgar entrar en una guerra?
¿Qué le preocupa realmente a Vladimir Putin? Hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero antes,
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA GRAN NACIÓN RUSA
¿Alguna vez os habéis preguntando de dónde viene
la palabra “Rusia”? Pues viene del “ANTIGUO RUS”,
que fue una federación de tribus, principalmente
eslavas ¿Dónde creéis que tenía la capital?
¿Moscú? ¿San Petesburgo? Pues no: la capital
estaba en KIEV, en la actual ucrania.
Dicho de otra forma: podemos decir que
los primeros rusos de la historia vienen
de la actual Ucrania. El antiguo Rus llegó
a ser el estado más grande de toda Europa.
Sin embargo, en el siglo 13, los mongoles, al
mando de BATU KHAN, destruyeron esta federación.
Y diréis ¿Pero por qué nos
remontamos tan atrás en el tiempo?
Pues por dos razones: la primera, porque es
importante que entendamos el papel que juega
Ucrania en la identidad rusa. De hecho, todo
lo que os estoy contando ahora está sacado,
literalmente, de discursos de Vladimir
Putin (Si algún ucraniano se siente
ofendido o piensa que estoy diciendo alguna
inexactitud histórica... ¡Ey! ¡Esto es sólo
la narrativa rusa!) La segunda razón por la que
nos remontamos tan atrás en el tiempo es porque
tenemos que entender que Ucrania, como entidad
nacional, es un país muy joven. Quiero decir,
el territorio que ahora ocupa Ucrania
ha estado poblado por toda clase de
etnias y ha formado parte de toda clase
de imperios. De hecho, el propio nombre
de “UCRANIA” viene de “OKRAINA”, que
en ruso antiguo significa “periferia”.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 1569, buena parte
de este territorio pertenecía a la Mancomunidad de
Lituania. Habéis oído bien. Hoy en día Lituania es
un país relativamente pequeño. Pero, por aquellos
años, Lituania abarcaba casi toda Polonia y parte
de Ucrania. Eso explica que la nobleza y las
élites fueran católicas. Pero la zona de Crimea,
sin embargo, era mayoritariamente musulmana.
Estaba ocupada por los famosos TÁRTAROS (que,
por cierto, no tienen nada que ver con la salsa
tártara, por si alguno lo iba a buscar en Google).
Sin embargo, al menos según la narrativa rusa,
la gente común en estas tierras hablaba ruso y
profesaba la religión ortodoxa. Principalmente
los cosacos. Los cosacos eran otra etnia más
de las muchas que vivían por aquí. Y estaban
cada vez más hartos de la nobleza lituano polaca.
Así es como estalló una guerra contra Lituania. Y
así es como, en el año 1686, Kiev pasó a control
cosaco. Toda la zona controlada por los cosacos
se llamaba “MALOROSSIA”, es decir, “la pequeña
rusia”. Los cosacos se integraron en la nobleza
rusa. Y durante siglos, miles de ucranianos
emigraron a Rusia como si fuera parte de su
misma patria. Para que os hagáis una idea, uno
de los novelistas más importantes de la cultura
rusa es NIKOLÁS GOGOL. Escribió en ruso toda su
vida. Sin embargo, nació en la actual Ucrania.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque estamos
ya en el siglo 20 y todavía no existe
ninguna entidad nacional que podamos
llamar Ucrania. De hecho, tras la
revolución bolchevique, el mapa estaba así.
Como véis, hay una parte que sí pertenecía a
la Unión Soviética. Pero todavía había regiones
dentro de Polonia y otras dentro de la antigua
Checoslovaqua. De hecho, cuando se creó la Unión
Soviética, la República de Donestk quería formar
parte de la República Rusa. Fue Lenin quien
decidió que pasara a formar parte de la nueva
República Democrática de Ucrania, que a su
vez estaba dentro de la Unión Sovietica.
Dicho de otra forma: la Ucrania que hoy conocemos
surge después de la Segunda Guerra Mundial. Ahí es
cuando Rusia decide que parte de los territorios
conquistados entren a engrosar el territorio
ucraniano y no el ruso. Y diréis ¿Por qué? ¿No
querían que Rusia fuera más grande? Pues lo
cierto es que, por aquel entonces, la frontera
entre Rusia y Ucrania importaba más bien poco.
Pensadlo bien, ambos países formaban parte de
la Unión Soviética. Ambos estaban controlados
desde Moscú. Ambos tenían cultura y tradiciones
rusas. Ambos formaban parte de un mismo pueblo
eslavo. Todo lo demás era accesorio.
Sin embargo, en el año 1991,
Ucrania se independizó. Y eso a Rusia
no le hizo la más mínima gracia.
Según la narrativa soviética, fue Rusia quien
reagrupó distintas etnias y regiones y las
unificó en torno a un concepto nacional único.
De repente, después de que todo esto ocurriera,
llegan los ucranianos y deciden
independizarse ¿No os parece injusto?
Pues... ¡Puede ser! ¿El problema? El problema
es que este mismo argumento se podría aplicar
para infinidad de países que fueron colonizados
¿Qué creéis? ¿Que la India existía antes de que
llegaran los británicos? ¡Evidentemente
no! Antes de la colonización británica,
el territorio de la India y Pakistán era una
amalgaba de reinos y tribus. De repente llegan
los britáticos y lo unifican todo dentro
de una misma colonia. Años más tarde,
los habitantes de esa colonia se independizan
pero mantienen las mismas fronteras coloniales.
Lo mismo se puede decir de casi cualquier
país de América Latina. Sin embargo,
creo que pocos justificarían que España
reclame Colombia a estas alturas alegando
nosequé razones históricas. Pero la
pregunta, la auténtica pregunta es... ¿De
verdad Putin está tan preocupado por las razones
históricas? Pues no. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LO QUE REALMENTE IMPORTA
Rusia tiene miedo que la OTAN coloque misiles
balísticos apuntando a su frontera. Peor aún,
Rusia tiene miedo de que la OTAN coloque cabezas
nucleares apuntando a Moscú. Y diréis ¿En serio?
¡Pero si la OTAN ya tiene cabezas nucleares! Pues
sí, tenéis razón: tanto la OTAN como Rusia tienen
arsenal nuclear y misiles balísticos apuntándose
el uno al otro. Ahora bien: no es lo mismo tener
un misil balístico en el Oeste de Alemania,
a 2000 kilómetros de distancia de Moscú, que
tenerlo en la frontera con Ucrania, que está a
700 kilómetros. En otras palabras: Rusia no quiere
que la OTAN tenga países miembros en su frontera.
(Pero ¡Ojo! No penséis que los rusos son unas
pobrecitas víctimas de la OTAN. Ellos tienen
una base militar gigantesca en Kaliningrado,
que hace frontera con Polonia y Lituania. Y ya
os podéis imaginar lo que puede haber por ahí).
Tenemos que recordar una cosa muy importante:
la OTAN es una alianza militar creada con
el propósito de defenderse contra la Unión
Soviética. Es decir, que es el antagonista
número uno de Rusia. Por supuesto, en los años
90 firmaron una especie de declaración de paz y
prometieron que nunca harían ejercicios militares
cerca de Rusia. Sin embargo, desde entonces, la
OTAN no ha dejado de expandirse hacia el Este.
En el año 1999 entraron Polonia, Hungría y
República Checa. En 2004 entraron los Bálticos,
Rumanía, Bulgaria, Eslovaquia y Eslovenia.
Vamos, que cada vez están más cerca de Rusia.
Desde la óptica del Kremlin, esto es toda una
traición y una maniobra agresiva. Por supuesto,
desde la óptica de la OTAN, la historia es
muy distinta: son todos esos países quienes
voluntariamente deciden unirse a la unión. Y
tiene bastante lógica que quieran formar parte
de la OTAN. Todos ellos son países que fueron
invadidos por la Unión Soviética y que quieren
escapar de la influencia rusa. Es lógico que
quieran la protección de Estados Unidos y el
resto de países europeos. Eso explica que,
por ejemplo, todos los edificios oficiales
de Lituania tengan banderas de la OTAN
junto a su bandera nacional y la europea.
Y diréis ¿No exageran un poco? ¿Por qué tienen
tanto miedo de Rusia? Si el miedo a una posible
invasión rusa podía parecer exagerado, en el
año 2014, Putin demostró que era muy real. Sí,
amigos de VIsualPolitik, 2014 fue el año en el
Putin invadió la península de Crimea y apoyó a
los separatistas del Este de Ucrania. Y lo hizo
porque, simplemente, Ucrania quería hacer un pacto
de libre comercio con la Unión Europea.
¿Y
cuál ha sido la reacción de Ucrania? Pues, en
cierto modo, podemos decir que Rusia ha perdido
mucho con esta invasión. No sólo hablamos de
las sanciones a la economía rusa. El apoyo a
la OTAN se ha disparado en casi toda Ucrania. Los
Ucranianos no quieren oír hablar de Rusia... salvo
los que viven en las regiones del Este:
es decir, en el llamado DOMBÁS. Y ahora,
la pregunta que muchos os estaréis haciendo
es... ¿Por que ahora, en 2022, Putin quiere
volver a tocar los tambores de guerra? ¿Por
qué ahora? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
PILLADO CON LOS PANTALONES BAJADOS
Rusia ha colocado a más de 100.000
soldados en la frontera con Ucrania
armados hasta los dientes. Hay incluso
tanques. Llevan en la zona desde otoño de 2021.
Para que os hagáis una idea, esto es la cuarta
parte de todo el ejército de Ucrania al completo.
Como ya hemos visto en anteriores vídeos de
VisualPolitik, Ucrania no es capaz de resistir
un ataque ruso a gran escala. Sí, es verdad:
desde 2014, el ejército de Ucrania se
ha modernizado. Ahora tienen armamento y
entrenamiento de Estados Unidos. Lo que antes era
un ejército corrupto y que ni siquiera tenía cómo
vestir a todos los soldados, ahora es algo mucho
más serio. Ahora bien, sin un refuerzo de la OTAN,
es casi imposible que resistieran a un ataque a
gran escala. Por el momento, a duras penas se han
movilizado tropas. Y no está claro que todos los
miembros de la OTAN estén dispuestos a hacerlo.
Así que Rusia ha aprovechado la situación para
escribir su carta a Santa Claus ¡Habéis oído bien!
En diciembre de 2021, la Embajada Rusa presentó
sus demandas ante la Casa Blanca. Es decir,
sus condiciones para empezar a negociar una
hipotética retirada de las tropas. Y bien digo:
es una Carta a Santa Claus. Es decir, una
serie de peticiones que son prácticamente
impensables. Entre otras cosas, Rusia exige
que la OTAN no acepte nuevos miembros ¡Pero
no sólo eso! También piden que la OTAN
no vuelva a hacer ejercicios en países
del Este. Dicho de otra forma: Rusia quiere
decirle a una serie de estados soberanos lo
que pueden hacer con sus ejércitos dentro
de sus propias fronteras nacionales.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Rusia sólo quiere negociar
con Estados Unidos. Es decir, que dan por sentado
que la OTAN no es un interlocutor. El resto de
Estados europeos que forman parte de la alianza
no tienen el más mínimo interés para Putin.
Aunque de eso hablaremos en próximos vídeos,
porque ya os adelanto que el tema de Ucrania va
a tener muchos vídeos aquí en VisualPolitik. Si
no os los queréis perder, ya sabéis, suscribíos
y dadle a la campanita para que os llegue una
notificación cuando actualicemos.
Pero sigamos con nuestra historia.
Porque ahora las preguntas son ¿Qué quiere
Putin exactamente con estas demandas?
Pensadlo bien: esto es una apuesta arriesgada
como pocas. Básicamente, Rusia está demostrando
que está dispuesta a atacar Ucrania total o
parcialmente ¡No sólo eso! Está demostrando que
tiene recursos para hacerlo. Y está poniendo
unas demandas totalmente maximalistas para
sentarse a negociar. La pregunta es ¿Es esto un
pretexto para justificar una guerra? No tenemos
la respuesta. Pero es difícil de pensar. A Rusia
no le interesa una guerra abierta ¿Puede ser una
forma de testear hasta dónde está dispuesta a
llegar la OTAN? Esta hipótesis tiene más lógica.
Tal vez pueda servir para mejorar su postura
negociadora. Pensadlo así: no tiene sentido que
Rusia quiera invadir toda Ucrania. La mitad del
país se revelaría contra el invasor y sería una
guerra de desgaste larga y tediosa. Y ya sabéis
cómo terminan las guerras de desgaste largas y
tediosas. Si no, le podéis preguntar a Biden
por su experiencia en Afganistán. Sin embargo,
no sería descabellado pensar que Putin
quiera partir Ucrania en dos. Es decir,
que las regiones del Este (el llamado DOMBÁS) se
conviertan en una república satélite de Rusia.
Teniendo en cuenta que la mayoría de la población
en estos sitios es rusoparlante, no es una idea
descabellada. Por otro lado, no sería la primera
vez que Ucrania cambia sus fronteras de nuevo.
Pero todo esto son especulaciones. Así
que ahora, turno para vosotros ¿Creéis
que veremos guerra abierta en Ucrania?
¿Llegaremos a ver un nuevo mapa de Ucrania,
con las repúblicas de Donestk y Luhanks siendo un
país independiente? ¿O tal vez la OTAN será capaz
de frenar a Vladimir Putin? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios. Como siempre,
no olvidéis que aquí, en VisualPolitik, sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos
vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.